what's up guys and welcome to Hardy's
hobbies the channel where we delve into
newest tech news and discuss the newest
tech products so today we're taking a
look at why it AMD is actually forcing
Intel to bring 8 cores and 16 threads
onto the mainstream market but before we
do that make sure you hit that subscribe
button if you guys haven't already to be
updated with the newest tech news lay it
to gaming and PCs so how is AMD forcing
intone well if you guys haven't already
heard about the news rise m2 is actually
coming up very soon and these are just
leaks so make sure to keep that in mind
but these leaks are very promising for
example horizon 2 2700 X is supposedly
going to bring 8 cores and 16 threads at
3.7 base frequency gigahertz and 3 4.35
you heard max frequency at wait for it
only 370 dollars now that's still a lot
of money but compared to the 1800 x
which was less powerful which came in
out $500 and now that 8700 k which has
two low scores and for less threads and
actually less of a max frequency at 4.30
acres but that's $10 more and $380 so as
you can see md is bringing absolutely
spectacular value with their new 2700 X
now I do realize that inta has much
better overclocking Headroom than AMD
for example going back to the 8700 K the
8700 K will is easily able to overclock
to 5 gigahertz like for example I have
all my cards right here at behind me
overclocked apply of gigahertz but you'd
probably have to get lucky just to
simply be able to overclock all of the
2700 XS course to 4.35 meters as a
result the rise in cpus can't be
stretched as much but you do have to
admit that AMD is still bringing great
value furthermore Amy's actually
including their rate aspire prism
coolers in their 2,700 X
in fact they're actually bringing in
their great stock clothes for all their
CPUs not just the non excellence even on
the excellence they have CPU coolers as
opposed to 87k which doesn't even have
their Intel stock crappy cooler once
again as you can see AMD is absolutely
dominating the value for the dollar
well what AMD is bringing out is great
value in everything but how exactly is
that forcing Intel to respond well
obviously in to has been losing a lot of
market share and in my opinion if they
continue to not give us eight cores 16
threads with much better performance and
value like AMD is then they're gonna
keep losing our market share
exponentially AMD literally has a
octa-core processor which is cheaper
than their hexa core processor so
obviously there's a problem that ain't
us to deal with
not to mention has more PCIe lanes and a
stop cooler with it as a result I
believe that Intel is already planning a
octa-core processor and that's probably
what Z 390 is all about it's probably
just a coffee like refresh and the 40
nanometer process but it'll have eight
cores and 16 threads similar to isin and
hopefully this CPU is just like all
those other CPUs with with it's crazy
high overclocking Headroom so these
crazy high core count CPUs are coming
out very soon but does that mean you
should buy them well honestly you
shouldn't because that's how your
performance is really not necessary and
if you're building a PC just for gaming
then you have to remember that more core
counts doesn't actually help gaming
nowadays the main bottleneck is GPUs and
we all know what's happening with GPUs
right now so as a result more coarse
isn't actually going to help you so does
that mean this whole like crazy value
and things aren't gonna help you at all
well just because this crazy new value
isn't gonna affect you directly doesn't
mean that it's not gonna help you at all
for example if the 9700 K comes out to
be a 8 core 16 thread processor
then at least after a few generations
the i5 Knights we will definitely be
upgraded for example the i5 it could go
to BS hexa core with 12 threads or even
an octa-core with no hyper threading
both of those will be much superior
option to what we have right now plus
the i5 S&I 3s are much cheaper than the
AI sevens
for example the i5 is usually a hundred
dollars cheaper than b i7 so you're
basically getting a current generation
8700 k for $100 cheaper if that's what
intel plans to do with the 9600 k so as
you can see AMD is bringing better value
for everyone as always competition is
always good for its consumer I also
believe AMD will make Intel do other
things for example I think Intel will be
more lenient with their motherboard
chipset lifespans because AMD obviously
is killing it Derek - with 4 plus years
while indolic last generation they only
had one ear I also think that Intel will
be forced to bring in more PCIe lanes
and offer hyper-threading for their
lower level CPUs as well hopefully Intel
will also bring the ability to overclock
all their CPUs and of course better
stock coolers overall as you guys can
already see am DS absolutely dominated
market right now with their crazy value
and they're even beating their value
with their new CPUs so AMD is really
showing what's possible and so int
elastic at least match the competition
if they want to be able to survive
because if you don't even match the
competition then why would people buy
their CPUs as a result I think Intel is
being forced by AMD to bring up eight
cores and 16 threads onto the main
stream platform but that's pretty much
all I have for you guys this time make
sure to post in the comments down below
what you guys are thinking about this
for example are you ecstatic that AMD is
bringing all this competition and lower
prices and better performance and do you
think AMD is making in toe sweat or do
you think Intel's always preparing
they're just a bit lazy and didn't think
they had to release it but now that the
time has come they'll release it and
once
dominate the market very soon make sure
to post you guys thinking because I do
read all my comments and I'm curious as
to what you guys think also if you guys
like this video then make sure to drop a
like on it and don't forget to subscribe
and hit that Bell notification if you
want to see more videos just like this
but until next time bye
[Music]